like knoxville kind of saw my humor
online but it's different you can be
funny online does it transcend in person
how did knoxville find you
on like i said instagram yeah i had a
joke um i don't know if it was this one
initially but i noticed after like my oj
joke got put up by the laugh factory it
got four million views on instagram and
i got 15 000 followers and a bunch of
like you know
bigger accounts started following me and
it was around that time so i don't know
if it was initially that or if just the
algorithm brought me
you know in front of his algorithm
and yeah and then he just was very
supportive of my content on online and a
lot of it was you know observational
very much jackass style you know butt
stuff [ __ ] jokes dick jokes
you know that
was very influential on my childhood
yeah
so so he sent you um it was his first
message about like hey we're gonna make
a new movie the message was hey
um
it was hey i wanna
can i give you a call i wanna
see if you're interested in something i
wanna talk to you it was like an initial
like i want to see if you're interested
in something basically so i gave him my
number and then
like five minutes later he called me and
that's when he would he said it was an
anniversary special right i didn't know
it was a movie but whatever it was he
said it was jackass and as soon as i
heard jackass which in my heart i was
hoping he was saying which would you
know and he's like is that would you
want to come in for a meeting with me
and jeff and i was like yeah so i went
in for the meeting and all they said was
we're going to be shooting i think
initially in october
the first when they the first discussion
right but it ended up getting pushed way
way back right right it was december the
test yeah and would you want to come
play with us kind of thing and i was
like yeah but i didn't know what that
meant i just was down to clown like it
didn't matter but i did say i was like
hey if you guys have any writing
sessions like i would be so down to
participate because that's where my
strength lies in writing so your
boyfriend mm-hmm and now you're engaged
no no just a boyfriend well pump the
brakes you know
now they are
okay um so your boyfriend like
what was that conversation like you yeah
i got a dm from knoxville
you know we didn't uh matt and i started
dating maybe like
um
a couple months after that
and i didn't tell anyone i didn't tell
i was going through a breakup at the
time and it was actually a really like
hopeful
thing in my life that i didn't i was
like i don't know if that's how this is
going to play out but i just received a
call from knoxville like i'm doing good
you know like [ __ ] that guy who who we
bro i broke up with oh okay um you know
and and so
it was um matt and i started dating in
july like right around this time three
years ago so that phone call was i think
may
right it's about it sounds about right
and so
you know i didn't tell him right off the
bat
because i'm not gonna be like hey just
so you know right i just kind of like
casually as we got to know each other
let him know that um i've been having
conversations but don't tell anyone
because sure did he get intimidated
no he was so stoked
her boyfriend's the man i
love him he's so nice he's and he loves
you guys and he grew up as much a
jackass fan like all of us and i think
you know for him
it's also he's a comedian too so for him
to see
a
young comedian come in hit the ground
running [ __ ] hustle like he knew and
saw me and heard about me before we
started dating and saw the content i put
online and even like was aware of oh wow
she's like in she's really good at this
internet stuff
and um he was stoked he was stoked cool
yeah how'd you guys meet did you slide
into your dms
actually i slid into his oh really yeah
i did
um we met at the comedy store we were
both dating other people
and a mutual friend introduced us and um
what'd you say
i said hey can you take this picture of
me and my hot friend like and he ended
up taking a selfie of himself
so i had that picture of him
and
i think we didn't speak until maybe
three years after that
yeah
um and i found out he is he had become
recently single and his mentor was jeff
garlin and he jeff is also a mentor of
mine um and
i
knew that so i hit up jeff and i was
like it was actually father's day and
jeff and i went and had lunch on
father's day and i was like hey you know
your opener matt like what's his deal
and he was like
it's perfect and nice you know we ended
up
meeting up after i love your boyfriend's
joke and by the way her boyfriend's name
is matt matt edgar yeah matt with one t
matt edgar he says uh you know dating
my girlfriend you know she's working on
jackass and you know people ask me like
man you must be like threatened like she
said they're going hanging around all
these naked dudes with their dicks out
and everything and he's like
well it does bother me because i want to
be there yeah like i grew up on those
days
he's like if i ever saw pontius's penis
in person i get star-strucked you know
yeah i'd ask for a dick pic
he's so stoked and it honestly it
wouldn't have worked out with me and
someone who wasn't supportive i would
have broken up with him and for sure
yeah yeah pontius must have the record
for like dick time on me is it is that a
real thing is somebody look that up
but mr skin where are you at
yeah i mean that's like six seven
minutes of solid big time guinness book
of world records i know yeah
i think that clip was awesome but not as
awesome as my new book a hard kick in
the nuts what i've learned from a
lifetime of terrible decisions which is
out september 27th and if you pre-order
it right now you can get the autographed
copy so get on it man pre-order my book
it's not going to waste your time
because i'm proven dude new york times
bestseller my first books five star
rated on amazon and i have no doubt this
one will be two so get the autographed
copy right now
by pre-ordering it at stevo.com
yeah dude